I'm cement Cavani from Microsoft
Research Redmond I'm going to tell you
about a new feature in Excel 2013 called
flash fill which had its origins in
Microsoft Research suppose you have a
collection of Social Security numbers
that you see in the first column and you
want to format them by inserting hyphens
as you see in the second column if you
have hundreds and thousands of these
rows then doing it manually would be
very cumbersome a more principled way to
do this would be to write an Excel macro
but if you are a non programmer like
most Excel users then you would be stuck
but now you can use the flash fill
feature to automate this task by just
the press of control e which is a
shortcut for flash fill the flash fill
feature builds over our program
synthesis technology that can generalize
examples into programs so this is the
opposite of program verification
methodology that is used to generate
test cases from programs to expose bugs
in those programs and this has seen
decades of research but now program
synthesis does the reverse it takes test
cases or examples and generates programs
that are consistent with those examples
in fact we generate a huge number of
such programs but we have efficient data
structures and algorithms to compute and
represent such programs then we use the
machine learning technology to rank
these programs we take the highest
ranked program and run it on all the
rows in the spreadsheet
to give the user the output that they
desire now in general it might not be
possible to learn the user's intent from
just one example as would be shown by
the second scenario where I have a bunch
of medical billing codes some of which
are missing a right bracket at the end
while some of which have a right bracket
suppose my goal is to clean this data by
adding a right bracket wherever it is
missing so if I give one example then
flash will generalizes it into a
simplest program which is to add a right
bracket everywhere maybe this is what
the user wanted but otherwise the user
would observe that rows 6 to row 10 are
all incorrect and the user can fix any
one of these rows so the moment I fix
row 6 then flash fill is able to fix
other similar rows
accordingly flash will can also be used
to perform complicated extraction tasks
so consider this worksheet there is a
lot of customer data in the first
column so suppose my goal is to extract
the constituent elements all that I have
to do is to give an example in each
column and hit ctrl e flash fill can
also synthesize programs that have
limited form of conditionals and loops
as is illustrated by this scenario where
I want to generate an abbreviation if
you want to learn more about this
technology then you can look at our CSM
research highlights paper you can also
use this feature yourself in Excel 2013